[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAY MOUNT: I'd like to introduce
my partner, Don Tyler, who's
helped me develop
this new program.
Don?
DON TYLER: So I'm Don Tyler.
I'm helping Ray develop the
program as a co-founder role.
My background is, I
own a dessert business.
I'm an executive coach
and a guide in training.
I've done the program with him.
We did a weekend.
We went away.
We did hiking.
And since then,
I've been working
on my own daily
practice in the woods
to kind of deepen this work.
And I'm here to support
Ray in any way I can
and answer questions later.
RAY MOUNT: How many hikers
do we have in the group?
Yeah, OK.
So after 30 years
as a psychologist,
seeing individual
clients in groups
and all different issues,
I decided to retire
and needed a break.
So where did I go?
Out on the Appalachian Trail.
So I went out with the lens
of a psychologist and an IFS
therapist.
IFS stands for internal
family systems.
So that's how I saw
the Appalachian Trail.
Although I had spent years
going into the White Mountains
and climbing all the 4,000-foot
peaks and running the trails,
my real interest in going out
on the Appalachian Trail was
to spend time with me.
And so that's what this
presentation is about.
I'm going to try to
take you on a hike,
or offer you an opportunity to
take a hike by watching some
of the pictures that I have.
There are over 5,000.
So I didn't bring
them all today.
Not to worry.
And then what happened during
my hike developed into a program
that Don and I are
trying to roll out now.
Basically, it's
therapy in the woods.
So if you have any
questions about that,
we have a website that
you can check out.
What is the Appalachian Trail?
Well, 2,200 miles.
It goes from Georgia to Maine
and passes through 14 states.
It's hard and it's long.
So here's a little history.
It's kind of a crowded slide.
I didn't really put it
up there for information.
I think I just put it up
there because I was impressed
with the number of traumas and
use of the trail as a place
to go to kind of relieve
yourself of burdens.
So the founder of the
Appalachian Trail,
the guy who came up with
the idea, Benton MacKaye,
he had just lost his wife.
So what he did, he connected
with all his hiking buddies
up and down the
coast, and he said, I
had this vision to put together
a hiking trail from south
to north along the east coast.
Send me your favorite hike.
So think about that.
You have a friend,
and you're going
to send him your favorite hike.
So that really describes
the Appalachian Trail.
This thing goes up and
over the craziest places.
And it really is challenging
in every section of it.
The first person who really
hiked it was Earl Shaffer.
He was a frontline radioman
in the Second World War.
And he hiked it to
hike off the war.
And today, every year,
hundreds and hundreds
of veterans coming back from
combat are hiking off the war.
So I got to meet
a number of them.
And I always ask,
what is it about being
out here that's helpful to you?
So that was my curiosity.
Emma Gatewood is
one of my heroes.
Grandma Gatewood,
they called her.
And she was a domestic
abuse survivor
who went out and hiked to hike
off the abuse, if you will,
on the trail.
She did it three times.
And she did it with a gunny
sack thrown over her shoulder
and tennis sneakers.
So the other thing
impressive to me
is, in 1968, Congress
passed something.
[LAUGHTER]
The National Trails System Act.
OK, let's play "Stump
the Google Staff."
I couldn't help
myself with this.
So what is the highest point
along the Appalachian Trail?
AUDIENCE: Mount Washington?
RAY MOUNT: Say again?
AUDIENCE: Is it
Mount Washington?
RAY MOUNT: Nope.
It's Clingman's Dome.
I thought it was
Mount Washington too.
Clingman's Dome is in the
Great Smoky Mountains,
between Tennessee
and North Carolina.
It's 6,643 feet.
And Mount Washington's
only 6,266.
So I went running up Clingman's
Dome, got to the very top,
and there's a tower
that you walk up on.
And it was pea soup fog.
So I didn't get to see anything.
What's the correct
pronunciation for Appalachian?
AUDIENCE: "Appa-latch-un?"
RAY MOUNT: Well, that's good.
It's "Appa-latch-un"
when you're in the south.
And as soon as you get
to the Mason-Dixon line,
then you call it
"Appa-lay-chun."
So they all knew that
I was from the north.
What's the length of
the Appalachian Trail?
AUDIENCE: 2,200 miles.
RAY MOUNT: Yup.
[LAUGHTER] You
heard me say that.
All right.
2,189.
It changes.
It was 2,000.
And it's grown over the years.
How long does it take
the average hiker
to hike the entire trail?
AUDIENCE: Four months.
RAY MOUNT: Four months.
Kids!
[LAUGHS] It took this
guy seven months,
with a lot of zero days.
Zero days means that
you try to recuperate.
How many calories per day does
a 150-pound person hiking the AT
burn?
AUDIENCE: 4,000.
5,000.
RAY MOUNT: 4,000, 5,000, 6,000.
That's right.
So if you break that down
into weight of carrying--
weight to carry-- it's about 10
to 15 pounds of food you carry.
When you go out in
the bush, you go out
for five or six days,
four or five days.
So we were always trying to
balance number of calories
with amount of extra weight.
So that's why we all
ended up very skinny.
The good old days.
I miss it.
[CHUCKLES]
So lessons along the trail--
165,000 white blazes,
and they became precious.
Wow, another white blaze.
Except they're the same whether
you're going north or south.
So I discovered
that several times.
One story is that
I had just seen
the second time the same spot.
And I thought to myself,
isn't this wonderful?
Wow.
I climbed the mountain and the
same exact spot on that side
is this side.
That's really interesting.
And as I finally got
reoriented and turned around,
I saw a guy my age at the top
of the mountain going around
in circles.
He said, hey, are you on
the Appalachian Trail?
So I didn't know what
to say, because it
was the wrong way on the trail.
So he said, stop,
don't go anywhere.
So he came down and we talked
about these two old guys
disoriented and
really not knowing
which way they're going.
But at least we were
on the trail together.
So that was fun.
262 shelters with
campsites along the trail.
In the Smokies, they want you
to stay there in the shelters,
keep all the campers
in one place.
But as soon as we could, we
got away from the shelters
and into the wilderness.
27-pound pack, which included
all the food and water.
I usually carried
about a liter of water
and then a filter to filter
water from the streams.
There's a hand-pump-- three
to eight liters a day,
so my hand got kind of tired.
This is a typical meal.
You see the 6,000 calories.
There's cheese,
rice, and hot dogs.
These damn hot dogs could
stay in your pack for a week.
I couldn't understand
why they never spoil.
[APPLAUSE]
I got to love hot dogs.
Here's my Jetboil.
And here's the
different campsites.
The one in the lower right
was about the third night,
fourth night out, in Georgia.
And that night is
the first time I ever
slept under a lightning
storm, holding onto the tent,
because of the wind.
I had it staked down,
but I was holding on.
Lightning, and aware of
that were dead trees around.
So I put my pack
frame over my head,
so only my body
would get crushed.
So this was a real
interesting experience.
And that picture always
reminds me of it.
This is what the
shelters look like.
I avoided them as
much as I could,
except one night
in North Carolina.
It got down to seven
degrees, and it was snowing.
It snowed about a
foot that night.
And so there were 12 of us
spooning in the shelter.
And I was glad to
have my buddies there.
It was really a great night.
This was the
preferred way to camp.
This is Jane Bald near
Roan Mountain in Virginia.
OK.
So here's the arch at the
beginning of the Appalachian
Trail, not quite.
From this arch, you still climb
another eight and a half miles
to get to the start of the
Appalachian Trail, which
is at the top of
Springer Mountain.
But I remember the
wonderful feelings of--
wow-- letting go.
And this was going to
be a wonderful sojourn,
a spiritual journey.
And I was going to do
all this work on myself.
Great expectations.
So how many people here have
it on their bucket list?
OK.
Be careful.
That's what happened to me.
I put it on my bucket list.
And then, once it's
there, it's got to happen.
AUDIENCE: What time
of year is this?
RAY MOUNT: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: What time
of year is this?
RAY MOUNT: Yeah, so March
6 was my start date.
And at the base of
the Appalachian Trail,
right at that arch,
is this quote.
I love this quote
from Harold Allen.
"Remote for detachment, narrow
for chosen company, winding
for leisure, lonely
for contemplation,
the trail beckons not merely
north and south, but upward
to the body, mind,
and soul of man"
So would you like
to take a hike?
All right.
I'll see if I can
pull it up for you.
I have a warning.
Music.
I sang my own music.
I made up songs.
I whistled.
I did drumming with my poles.
I was all about music.
So we have a little bluegrass
band, my partner and I.
And so that's where
this music comes from.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Sit back and relax.
[APPLAUSE]
How'd you like the music?
AUDIENCE: It was great.
RAY MOUNT: [LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking how wonderful
it is that you're
talented enough that you
could provide your own music.
RAY MOUNT: [LAUGHS]
Well, thank you.
That's good.
So how many of you use
nature and wilderness
to unwind, to rejuvenate?
How many?
Just put up your hand.
Really, it can be a tree, a
squirrel, chipmunks, deer.
Oh, my god.
The deer are beautiful.
And the bears really were
scary until I encountered them.
And I realized that
they have a soul.
They have thought,
wonderful feelings.
They raise little kids.
So that's what I learned
after this story.
So I went down the trail,
listening to my music,
unaware of anything.
And all of a sudden,
this little black bum
ran out in the middle of
the trail, shot ahead of me,
and right up a tree.
I thought, what was that?
So I turned, and
I'm looking around.
And this growl came out of the
bushes with this huge mother
bear right next to me--
closer than that-- five feet.
Yeah.
And so she was
fumbling another cub.
And so I did my procedure, which
is to make myself really tall
and hold up my poles
and click them.
And I backed up like this.
Mother bear came down
the trail like this.
And I was not afraid.
I'm afraid now when
I think back on it.
[LAUGHS] But I wasn't afraid.
And what I realized was, I
had practiced this procedure
if I ever encountered
a bear enough times.
I had actually rehearsed it.
And I was able to get
beyond my panic, my fright,
and feel compassion.
Because this was a mother,
two kids out of control.
One of them shoots in
front of this crazy hiker.
And the other one, she
didn't know where it is.
And she just wanted to
take care of her kids.
So those moments really
connected me to nature
and to the magic of it.
So I'm glad to see so many
of you are equally connected.
So I look at these two pictures
before and after the trail,
and I ask myself,
what's changed here?
More than what's changed,
how do I keep it?
So since then, I've been
going out into the woods
every day to do some
variation of a practice.
I thought of myself as
a trail yogi years ago
when I'd go up into
the White Mountains
and meditate on the
top of the mountain.
But after the hike,
I've really gotten
into finding that
energy from nature,
connecting with it, and
then, from that place,
examining all the stuff
that I'm going through,
all the stresses
that I put on myself.
So we're trying to roll
that out as a program.
This is my quote.
"The ideal of hiking the
entire trail in one season
was indeed romantic.
The reality, perhaps
a bit harsh."
Here was the trail.
I thought, March in Georgia
is going to be spring.
This is what we found.
This was a foot and a
half of snow on the tent.
The night before, we had
all spooned in the shelter
together.
And I said, ah, this is
just too close for me.
Seven degrees, though,
made it worth it.
This night, it was
recorded zero degrees.
I woke up, and my
sneakers were frozen.
And so the good and the
bad of it-- and sometimes,
it happens together--
was, I figured out how to thaw
out a sneaker by bending it.
And then finally, I was able
to get my Jetboil working
and boil a little water.
And just seeing myself
do these survival
things was a beauty
in itself, and really
made up for the cold.
I woke up to my bear bag.
We have to hang
everything in trees
to get the smell out
of the tent and food
away so the bears don't
come into the tent
get your food and you.
So there's my bear bag, that
orange one up there, hanging.
And I woke up, a coffee
addict, knowing that's
where the coffee was.
So fortunately, I got it.
And my granddaughter taught
me how to do selfies.
So I enjoyed a lot of selfies.
This is that day at the top
of Standing Indian Mountain.
It was "blizzardy."
Oh.
So it's not all bad.
We had what's
called trail magic.
And that is, all
of a sudden, when
you're really thirsty
or hungry, you
come upon this
little thing that's
been put out for you by another
hiking club or an individual.
And we call it trail magic.
One day, there was a
guy cooking breakfast
from the back of
his pickup truck.
Quiet Paul, his name was.
So this was trail magic.
So this was a terrible
day, mile 650.
It was a nine and half hour day.
I was hot, sweating.
I was just not in a good place.
And I came to the
War Spur shelter.
And lo and behold, I came
down at 6 o'clock, and I look.
There's an empty
shelter, the War Spur.
And there's wood
already to make a fire.
And you see the
Pabst Blue Ribbon.
So somebody left two
full cans of beer,
which I'm going to go take
and put them in a tree.
This is, like, my lucky day.
This is a lucky day.
[LAUGHS]
I'm glad I have video.
Because as the memories
fade, these things were real.
[LAUGHS] All right, trail names.
I didn't know
anyone's real name.
We all had trail names.
There's mine in the middle--
Mountain Music.
And yeah, I play
bluegrass music.
But it was really
about when I got going,
really got humming, and
got to be one with nature,
I could hear music
from the mountains.
And so I realized that
that was my trail name.
So I was Mountain Music.
Toodles worked for
the Democratic Party
somewhere in Washington.
When they were gone, he
said, to hell with this.
I'm going out on the trail.
So he was a friend.
X-Ray is from here--
X-ray technician from Boston.
Kaleidoscope was a woman.
She said she had a
kaleidoscope of issues
she was trying to
work out on the trail.
She was fun.
And Ghost Hiker was great.
Ghost Hiker would
hike along with us.
We'd see her now and then.
And all of a sudden, at
night, she'd disappear.
She had a hammock.
She would go into the
wilderness and find a place
for that hammock and come back.
One day, I asked her, how
are you so brave to do that?
I was trying not to be gender
thing about it, but the woman.
And she said, oh, yeah,
I love it out there.
She said, I'm not afraid at all.
Why not?
She was LAPD, retired.
[LAUGHS] So she was fun.
But spending six months alone
in the beautiful wilderness
with nothing but
my mind to keep me
company might have been boring
if I had been hiking alone.
But I wasn't.
Let me introduce my friends.
How many people meditate here?
OK.
When you begin, do you
go down and it's chaotic?
So that's what I experience too.
And this is a
representation of that.
But as we do trail meditation--
and here are the steps.
I've got it broken out
into the word PEACE.
The first step is to prepare and
to try to connect with nature.
But I'm able to find
this Mountain Music guy.
And my psyche can show up.
And from that place, I try
to examine parts of me--
see the parts in
the back of my head?
Parts that might be up.
In this case, this
one here in the center
is the pilot navigator part.
So I really got to know this
part and really respect it.
It was a pilot who's always
working for efficiency.
You've got to hike just
the right speed, just
the right amount of
water, the right weight.
Navigator was trying to keep
me in the right direction
on the trail.
So I got to know those parts.
But then this guy
over here showed up
in the back of my head.
And I had to look at him.
And he says, I'm not
going to make it.
So I very much had that part.
And so as I worked through
my trail meditation,
I spent a lot of time
in that higher place,
trying to connect with
the part that was afraid
and didn't think he was going to
make it, especially the climb.
Some of the climbs were
ferocious in the rain
and in storms.
So I spent a lot of time
quelling those fears.
And from that, this guy emerged.
And I call it The Mule.
And The Mule says,
we're going too fast.
Of course you're afraid.
We're going to slow down.
I said, well, that
sounds like a good idea.
So I tried it.
And what happened
in my head was,
the pilot part showed up again.
And The Mule-- see,
he's trampled him.
The Mule says, no,
we're going to go slow.
The Pilot says, whoa,
we've got efficiency here.
You're never going to make
Mount Katahdin in Maine.
You're not going to make it.
So I had a real battle.
Does anybody have battles in
their head to do the work?
OK, good.
So I had a real battle.
And what I did differently
was to take them on a hike.
I'd say, OK, this
is our hike today.
I want to hear from
both people, both parts.
And so I began to see how
much like good management
this really is--
applying all your
good management skills
to managing the
different voices,
different aspects of yourself.
That's what this program
we're trying to roll out
is all about.
What I did with these two
parts was to negotiate peace.
And it went like this.
When the slope gets
tough, inclined,
The Mule can stop and
stand there and not
move until he feels like it.
And that's OK with The Pilot.
It's OK with The Pilot
because it's not on the clock.
So I said, I'll take
responsibility for the time.
We'll figure out a way.
But right now, The
Mule gets his time.
So I was able to
plod up these hills.
So "Mountain Music--" me--
"could best manage
our inner world.
But at times, he would get
tired and disappear, burn out,
leaving a management vacuum."
That kicked my butt.
You're too damn
slow, he would say.
And so it brought up a child.
I like this little
cartoon picture--
I have the certifications
for each of these--
[LAUGHS] with a little
backpack on, sitting on a curb.
Does anybody have that
part once in a while?
Go there?
So he's called Slowpoke.
And so I did my
wilderness meditation
with Slowpoke and
Drill Sergeant.
Convinced Drill
Sergeant he was good.
I like him.
I need him.
He drives me through things.
I need discipline.
But you're hurting
the younger part.
You're hurting the
more vulnerable part.
So I got the drill
sergeant to see that.
I didn't know before
that we can really
work with the different
aspects of ourselves
if we pay them attention
and focus on them enough.
This is the guy that
developed, Good Step.
He became Sure Step, the
guy that could go down
the slippery rocks, have fun.
I like him.
He showed up-- Dead Man Walking.
This was July 27.
Today is-- what--
August 3.
So I did a blog.
You can check it out.
It's RayMountPsychologist.com.
But here was my jog entry on a
year ago today from this guy.
"The march up to New Hampshire's
over 4,000-foot mountain peaks
has been grueling.
So I'm taking a few days
off to rest, sail, and eat.
My legs feel like rubber.
And the thought of
climbing another mountain
seems torturous.
Last year, I would look forward
to coming up to the Whites
and climb two or three in
a weekend, all in good fun.
I miss the joy of climbing.
So I've decided to do it in four
day chunks, three days off."
Four-day hiking.
So I was able to renegotiate
and give my system what
it needed to enjoy this hike.
All right.
Who can guess what
the other part
is that's in my head
causing this guy?
AUDIENCE: Drill Sergeant?
RAY MOUNT: Got it.
That's a beer.
Drill Sergeant.
I want to leave some
time for your questions.
Team Meetings.
I'm a big believer that we both
become better outside managers
when we become better inside
managers, and vice versa.
When we become good
outside managers
and we can take those lessons
inside, it becomes seamless.
So I'm learning to be a
good manager of my guys.
We put a team through
this training.
And here's the team.
We had a great
time in the woods.
It was here at Hale Reservation.
Anybody go out there?
And there's wilderness
camping out there
and wonderful trails
to hike and run.
So we would do a
two-hour solo hike.
It's all solo hike.
And then we'd come
back and circle up
and talk about the experience.
And so we had our first class.
You see Don.
He's right in the center of it.
He was there.
We'll be doing more of that.
So the team wishes to
say goodbye and thank you
for listening-- my team.
And I want to dedicate this
presentation to the friends
that got me here.
So I'm drinking a beer
out of my water bottle--
I'll confess that--
and smoking a cigar
when I get down
from Mount Katahdin,
thanking my parts
that got me there.
Questions?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I have a somewhat
technical question.
You said that, going up
on one of the mountains,
you kind of lost the direction,
didn't know whether you
were going north and south.
I will figure that I
want to a hiking GPS
if we go up on our own.
How does that work?
RAY MOUNT: I have a GPS.
And let me tell
you how it works.
Take this thing into the
shower and try to move it.
It doesn't work.
A lot of times--
here it is.
This is my cell phone--
I couldn't take a picture.
I couldn't work a GPS.
And at other times, the Pilot
part and the navigator part
likes to fake it.
He says, don't worry about it.
We'll get there.
So I'm in a lot of
denial around that.
So I got in trouble.
And I learned about that
part and how important it is.
When it's chirping at me,
I need to stop and make
sure I know the directions.
I was a hyperactive ADD kid.
So working with
that is interesting.
GPS-- this iPhone
7-Plus was great.
Pictures, videos, GPS.
It gives internet at all
the hostels you can stay in.
So good question.
How'd you get lost, jerk?
There's only two ways to go.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Ray, let me ask you
two, I hope, quick questions.
One is, I'm curious about how
you prepared physically to do
this before you went on it.
And my second question
is, during the course
of this thing, did you have
any really serious injuries
or illnesses that caused you
to actually get treatment
off the trail that you
couldn't deal with yourself?
RAY MOUNT: Yeah.
I had no injuries that I had
to get treatment off the trail.
But I had severe shin
splints for three weeks.
And that's when I started
calling myself Slowpoke.
And that's when I really had to
work with that part, Good Step.
And we limped into Damascus.
And when I got into Damascus,
I knew I was done for a while.
So I took a room
for three nights.
So the first day of rest, I
was so excited to get back
into the mountains,
but I rented a bicycle,
and I went up that way.
So that was a little rehab.
And then the second day,
I took a slack pack,
which is, you dump your heavy
gear, take just a small pack,
and do a short distance.
Cut my distances down, soaked
my ankle regularly in streams,
and massaged it.
And I worked through it.
There's also some cannabis
cream that's pretty good stuff.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: How did you
prepare before the hike?
RAY MOUNT: Yeah,
preparing before the hike.
Well, you know,
I've always tried
to stay in some kind of
shape, physical condition.
And my method of choice
is usually trail running.
So I'm in the trails.
I'm running or hiking.
And then I did a lot, over
the 4,000-foot peaks--
I have all 48 of them now.
So I'd go up to the peaks
and I'd load my backpack up
with cans of food, and
I'd hike up and down
the peak for practice.
But in reality, you really
can't train for this.
You get in shape
as much as you can,
and you just start off
with what your body can
take and slow down.
Because the difference is
this is not a weekend thing.
It's chronic.
It changes everything.
And so it'd slow down.
So we would start with
only eight, 10 miles a day.
And then, as your body
and spirit can handle it,
you build up your distance.
AUDIENCE: I've heard about
youth programs related
to this, like wilderness
therapy programs for kids
through DYS and the juvenile
system and so forth.
I guess, as an
open-ended question,
in your mind, what's the
relationship between what
you're doing and that?
Is there any at all?
Can you imagine young people
being involved in this?
RAY MOUNT: Yeah,
I absolutely can.
And I'm in touch with--
I have not met yet--
Michael Glass, who's at the
University of New Hampshire.
And he's kind of a guru
of the programs around.
He does the certification
for youth programs.
But it's about using the magic
healing powers of nature.
You know, part of our
belief is that, as we've
evolved from nature, physically,
spiritually, in other ways,
also, our healing has
evolved from nature.
But it ended up the hospital.
So if we return to
nature, we can heal
spiritually, heal mentally.
The difference is that I'm
an IFS-trained therapist.
IFS-- Internal Family Systems.
And you go on the
website and check it out.
And it deals with parts.
Like, you're going
to work on your car.
So you think of your car,
your mind, as one thing.
So does the mechanic
think of it that way?
The mechanic's testing
which system it is.
Ah, here it is, a carburetor.
Now, I'm going to
take this apart
and I'm going to fix that.
That's this kind of therapy,
and that's how it's different.
You saw the slide with all the
mess of all the different parts
in it.
So what we're trying to do
is meditation to get down
to isolate one of those
parts until we feel good
towards the part and then,
really, work with it.
And in my case, I hiked with it.
We had many conversations.
We have a political part.
We ran for president--
[LAUGHS]---- gave
political speeches.
But it was all important for
me getting to know these parts,
like on your committees.
You get to know the
members of your committee.
And you'll be a better
manager as a result of that.
Did that answer it?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
RAY MOUNT: OK.
AUDIENCE: Completely
different kind of question--
why south to north?
Is that what everybody does?
How did you pick that?
RAY MOUNT: Yeah.
It's the traditional
way, south to north.
It works out, weather-wise.
But the trail folks today
advise not doing it that way.
Actually, they
advise flip-flopping
so you can do sections of the
trail when they're not crowded.
I went with a bubble--
very crowded.
We have maybe 5,000
people that started.
And maybe 1,000 finished
out of that group.
But resources were difficult.
If you can not do it
south to north, go for it.
If you can not do it in one
season, that's advised too.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: How much
does it matter
to do a line instead
of a loop when
you're thinking about
enjoying the wilderness
and experiencing it and
you're experiencing yourself?
RAY MOUNT: A line?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
doing it end-to-end.
Something at the end, instead of
coming back where you started.
RAY MOUNT: Yes, yes.
Well, you know,
what I've learned
about the wilderness
is, one, I haven't
known how to approach the
wilderness in a way that allows
me to really do meditation.
I'm too fast.
I have parts that push me
I want to get exercise in.
And I want to get time in.
And I want to go
end-to-end, you know?
And what I discovered
is that there's
a pace that I need to stay
at in order to really let
my mind open and empty.
And Don, if I can
use for an example,
his trail meditation is
sitting in the wilderness.
So here's what I'd suggest.
Go into the wilderness
stand there.
[LAUGHS] And see where
your body takes you.
I know a guy that plays with
the water in the stream.
But it's allowing yourself to
connect with what's around.
Can you do it here in the city?
Maybe.
Do you need nature?
Can you do it with a brick?
Maybe.
Or a computer?
I don't know.
No.
[LAUGHTER]
I agree.
But you know.
Inside, you know what
you need to have peace.
AUDIENCE: I always
thought that people
hiking the Appalachian Trail
would try to do it one season.
But it is recommended not doing
it in one season if you can.
Now, my question
is, how long do you
think you would need to be on a
hike to get really to the point
where you can let
go and meditate
and really get to the point,
whatever that point is?
RAY MOUNT: Well, I would say
that seven months is too long.
[LAUGHS] But on the
other hand, parts
came out in that
seven months when
I was burnt out that I
hadn't really seen before.
I think, in a couple
of minutes, some people
can get into a good meditation.
Who said they meditate here?
All right.
So how long?
AUDIENCE: Definitely 10
minutes, five minutes.
RAY MOUNT: 10
I think the answer is the same.
It's that you're unique.
So if you experiment and find
your place, find your way.
AUDIENCE: Ray,
there was a question
before about how you prepared
or didn't beforehand.
What was the longest
continuous hike
that you had done, in terms
of days out or nights out,
prior to doing the AT?
RAY MOUNT: Yeah.
So I did the Pemi
Wilderness for three nights.
I did three or four
peaks out there.
I did Owl's Head, came
down at nighttime.
I was frozen and
crossed the river.
So I'd done a lot of that.
I like to do that.
So I think that was my longest--
three days.
But it just changes
when it's three weeks.
When you're out there five
days, and you say, jeez,
did I talk to anybody today?
No.
Did I talk to anybody yesterday?
I don't think so.
Have I had reception
on my phone?
No.
It changes.
But it's fun.
You get to really know yourself.
That's the draw.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned many
times about hiking the peaks.
And I just wanted to say that
it's not just about hiking
the peaks.
I think you can have the same
experience just hiking flat,
or the peaks, or up and down.
And it's just about being where
it feels like you should be.
RAY MOUNT: Yes.
Yeah.
May I tell a story about that?
So I've been in the
Fells-Winchester reservoir.
Most days I go there, and
then I'll go other places.
One day, I was just so open.
It was my birthday, actually.
And I had someone call
me and sing to me.
But I was just so there,
connected to nature.
And I was running very slowly.
And I came across a deer.
And I slowed down, and I walked.
And the deer was on
this side of the road,
saw me, walked across the
road to the other side,
stood and looked at me,
and wagged his tail.
Have you ever seen
a deer wag its tail?
They flip their tail
up and they take off.
This deer wagged his tail.
And I felt like I could have
gone over and petted him.
But I didn't want
to invade his space.
So I walked--
I don't know-- this
far away maybe,
and we looked at each other.
And I was the one that
broke the contact.
I'd never had that experience.
And I can only attribute
it to, I was that open.
SPEAKER: OK.
Thanks, everybody.
Thank you, Ray.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RAY MOUNT: Thank you.
Appreciate it.